you wanted to get into that well now
what is your I guess perspective on that
okay here's a belly flop is uh shut up
you'd be happier at home let's cut the
crap most women will be happier at home
probably 95 percent they're just
pretending they like work and they have
stupid jobs and they don't even hold a
candle to being a mom so shut up have my
next guest there's actually a story
behind booking him before he broke the
internet but let me introduce him first
you can catch his podcast free speech
podcast on iTunes just google it you'll
find it send your Gavin McInnes thank
you for being on the show sir I adjusted
the mic levels and then and then he went
full Jerry Lewis so boom you know that
was Squiggy from Laverne and Shirley
remember hello that's right
I went you know why it's the Montreal in
me Gavin where they just love Jerry
Lewis remember oh you Frenchman you dog
I know
okay so Gavin but it's funny because we
were about to book you last week and
then some things fell through we had
that woman who converted from Islam and
yeah this is not the first time this
happened same thing with Chael Sonnen we
had him booked and then the john jones
controversy broke the anderson silva
controversy broke standing with you we
had you booked we moved you the next
week and then boom you blew up the
internet tell us I guess for those who
don't know yet what happened well the
way Greg Gutfeld puts it he goes you
made a big splash with a belly flop and
it could have been a swan dive if you
had cited the proper statistics instead
of just saying I read it in a book
but I did read it in a book and I am a
belly flop kind of guy like I'm not I'm
not Mark Phelps I'm John Belushi so why
do I have to I don't understand why the
right why white males have to tiptoe
around and deliver facts like they're
feeding a little squirrel in the park
and everyone else gets to just yell what
do we want dead cops what everyone's
right says dices scum why do they get to
have all the fun anyway on Fox News we
were talking about the Marley's were
dead to begin with okay the stage is set
that we were talking about the wage gap
and how Hillary Clinton paid her workers
less and this was supposed hypocrisy
I just brought up the fact that no all
women earn less across the board whether
they're working for Hillary or you know
the woman's foundation for equal pay or
they're working at Fox News and the
reason for this is women tend to put
family over work there's a great book
called why men earn more and it breaks
it all down he breaks it actually into
it breaks life into 25 choices and he
keeps finding time and time again that
they would rather be with their kids for
their daughters piano recital then stay
all night at work yeah duh and I don't
think that's the case I don't think
that's the case for Stephen and me I
think we got women who know how to make
a good dollar this is true yeah well the
big irony to it seems a conservative men
I mean I know we're hopefully going to
have her on the show always even though
we we believe in sort of I guess
complementarianism it seems to me the
conservative men always marry the
strongest women my wife is no shrinking
violet she has no problem swatting me in
the Costco parking lot because I locked
the keys in the car well if your wife
makes more money than you then she
married the wrong guy well no I minded
yeah even if she's a supermodel and she
makes more money than her her husband
she still married the wrong guy she
should have married like dodo Fayette or
whatever his name is
their fun dip that stings
oh no you lucked out I guess we're both
a couple of hapless dorks who happen to
do some classy broads well the thing
with you Crowder anyway is you're a
freak and in the that's not really that
profitable in this day and age if you're
going to say hate facts you're not gonna
get rich at least for the next few years
I tell you what actually full disclosure
right because we're gonna be doing some
crowd funding to fight Islam and I have
to tell the audience like I do pretty
well and I'm pretty grateful but my wife
does well too you know my wife does
really well and she's she's a working
woman and we have it quite clear that
listen she she's told me I don't want to
work when I have children
so that burden falls on me and she's
letting me know that and I'm I'm okay
with that so we've decided we're both
going to be sort of sprinting right now
we both work jobs were both
entrepreneurs and entrepreneur
and then you know she wants to be home
with the kids and that's okay and
because I love her and because a respect
her and because I'm sexist and I treat
women differently than men
I said yes so wait I don't get so she
does want to stay home with the kids
after she has kids after she has kids
but she wants to work up until then
well what happened my wife is she said
I'm going right back to work as soon as
they're born and then she saw how fun
they are the first seven weeks sucks
don't get me wrong the first seven weeks
blows but once they start sleeping
through the night and then when they
start walking and then when they start
talking now we're up to two years they
never want to go back to work and by the
way when I say never and when I say all
I don't I'm not sorry you can't swear on
this show right now because it is it
does go to actual locations as well I'm
not fudging Mal I'm not Stalin okay
nothing is all but when it's it should
be assumed that when we say nobody wants
to do this there are exceptions to the
rule but liberals always go oh really
women like staying at home with kids do
they well I found one person who doesn't
ergo everything you say doesn't exist
there's nothing creepier than you doing
the woman impression with your hand on
your hip and the prison tats like you
you got your kid potty-trained at seven
weeks no why so you're saying potty
training is the what the hump you have
to get over no because you're me kids
aren't fun until after their body drain
everything before that is a pain they
drink nothing but milk so their stool is
just a softball it's not like swiping
going on it's no problem
i won I changed like three three diapers
and I was like this is it yeah let me
know when he's potty-trained and I'll
take him to the Auto Show or something
I'm not doing that I actually dread my
youngest getting potty-trained because I
know he's our last and every diaper is
his sanctum sanctum out is sacred I
don't know what I do so sacred diapers
now that's gross what I do is this first
segment
devolved so quickly right into
scatological humor but I think
no Gavin it's funny that Greg said that
to you I don't I don't think it was a
belly flop I really don't I understand
where he's coming from but I understand
where you're coming from I do think
there are certain people who will be
closed off to it but I think like you
said in your YouTube video afterward a
lot of those people are people that you
just sort of have to resign yourself to
the fact that you're not gonna reach
some of them anyway so we have to go to
a break here but I want to bring you
back after and give you the floor Gavin
McGinnis ladder with Crowder's stay
tuned back with the one and only Gavin
McGinnis free speech podcast you can
find it on iTunes all over the web Gavin
okay so we're talking about the Fox News
controversy you then went on HuffPo what
you said was basically a video I mean I
released a video that debunked the the
wage gap myth a long a long time ago it
was during the Oscars and anyone who
cares looked that up a long time ago
exactly exactly so I'm gonna ask I want
to ask you something because President
Obama went up and said the 77 cents in a
dollar he quote yes dad and I'm sitting
there I'm going it is so patently
verifiably false no respectable
economists none acknowledged it they
they have to dismiss it even the
feminist ones they have to dismiss it as
frivolous yet you have President Obama
going out and spouting that so is it me
or does it does it beg the question okay
is he that stupid that he doesn't know
or is he proactively pulling you know
the wool over the eyes of the American
public here well I can't imagine that
his staff doesn't have access to Google
but let's just play devil's advocate
here maybe you know he is technically
right women earn 77 cents on the dollar
that is true the truth is they choose to
earn that because they'd rather be at
home with the kids but maybe he's saying
they shouldn't be at home with the kids
and they shouldn't choose that maybe in
his world they're men and women are
exactly the same and we stop having kids
I don't know or the kids end up in the
Obama youth yes yes if women earn the
same exact same as men it means they're
working as hard as men they're as driven
as men that means the kids have to be in
daycare that means the government is
bigger that means he gets more money
more power yeah we'll just think of
Montreal right now
I mean that's one thing I wanted to get
to so obviously everyone knows about the
the feminist deal and you've been going
on about that for a while they can fund
on your free speech podcast but we mean
you helped create right vice media was
it vice news revised media when you
created it
it's called vice media now it was called
voice of Montreal when we founded it
okay it was suroosh alvi and I and I
hired Shane to be my sales guy about two
years in okay because I remember you
know a lot of people don't realize we
were both lived there the same time I
was raised in Montreal so from three to
eighteen so entirely different
perspective we made asian boy watch it
get down no puta what he what are you
speaking Klingon funding yeah yeah we're
speaking in actual language one that
impresses women doesn't repulse them I
don't know
bleeping French word of French swear
words are all chair in a church when I
tell them well that's a great point too
you know in the United States I mean
they use the F word in French Canadian
as a verb right it's not a bad word
you'll hear it on prime-time television
oh they'll say it in daycares they'll
say words I can't say right now in great
yes but they're ignorant cuss words are
it's essentially like using the Lord's
name in vain you know I mean it'd be
like me right now saying Oh communion
wafer chalice literally the worst thing
you can say yeah people at home he's not
doing an analogy chalice is the worst
swear word in Quebec a tabernacle yeah
yeah a burn a chalice calvero what's
that I don't know I know uh eight is
damn that's yeah but but SC is communion
wafer yes and what's funny to fun dip
see you don't realize this two people
listening
that's why Canadians they use the F word
as a period so you'll have K they didn't
know how to swear properly they will go
ah this thing is broken f because in
French Canada what where it comes at the
end it's also being scotch-irish
in Ontario English Canada's founded by
Scots they're a drunk culture and drunk
people swear a lot so the Ottawa Valley
sounds like Scottish that's why they say
a but when we were kids
be throwing a softball and we would go
mmm mmm F like you catch and say F even
a surgeon if he was stitching up he go
yes it's very very common and it's it's
actually kind of annoying but I remember
so when I was a kid
do you remember no where did you live in
Montreal yeah I lived on the plateau
okay so do you member the big music
store our auction bow our Shambo I don't
think so okay well there was a big one
downtown but where I was in the South
Shore it was the big you know there was
HMV oh yeah yeah yeah this was down on
the st. catchment Street yes yes so
there was a big one on the south shore
our Shambo and they had all the you know
it was a music store and then they got
into books and magazines and so we'd
walk out and I always had the mirror and
they would have you know vice was there
I don't I can't member if it was I
remember seeing vice so I don't know at
what point did it become vice it became
vice in 96 okay he left the government
scam that it was it broke out and
changed the name okay because I remember
my parents my dad wouldn't make sure I
mean people don't understand this and I
know vice wasn't quite there but in in
Canada you have newspapers where they
will basically have like hardcore
pornography in Montreal on the cover
right yes some skittles once y'all
invented the tabloid did you know that
they invented the tabloid yep they were
the first all that like all the British
ones you see the National Enquirer all
that was started in in Montreal well
they were pretty rough though I mean
you'd see like the oh yes of a sexually
mutilated body and it'd be like it'd be
like right next to the slim jims yeah a
little police yep yes I would kill to
find an aloe Palace right now that means
hello police I know lok serese and coke
classique that's about it yeah I don't
care
why would I care that you know three
French words I don't know how dare you
fund it Audrey Joe - it's like someone
yesterday they goes hey I saw the
trailer of your movie I don't care he's
Gavin he cares not tell me when you've
seen it don't let me put money in my
pocket yeah but it's funny so that is a
culture right in Montreal and and I feel
like there are two
kinds of people who come out of there
Gavin people love you and I don't share
everything kind of a commonality people
like you and me sorry fun dip and then
there are people who don't even think
twice about it right I mean the rule is
what maybe 95 percent liberal there are
no conservatives in Montreal there's
liberal and liberal separatists and then
I feel like there are some people like
you and me who see it and go am I taking
crazy pills this is this is completely
off the plot well the thing people don't
get about where we come from is language
English versus French subsumes
everything there's no talk about
abortion or Islam or racism it's all
totally dwarfed by a by English versus
French it's like in Scotland they don't
really talk about politics outside of I
hate the English let's separate I mean
Scotland is like Quebec in that sense
and I always say Quebec is like this
teenager who's been saying I hate it
here you suck I'm gonna leave for 400
years you're like okay go they'd be
using the American dollar so faster to
make your head spin to already getting
eaten by New York with all their
electrical power but what I was going to
say is some of us English go wait a
minute there's literally language police
going around taking pictures of signs
and saying you wrote English too big we
get mad and it's like this pressure
cooker where you have to be a total
hustler to survive and that's why Dov
Charney comes out of Montreal that's why
you and I have this survival instinct
because we grew up basically in a
dictatorship I mean if you ever meet a
Chilean who grew up under Pinochet he's
a badass right yeah it's absolutely true
but it's it's funny because most people
are complacent and accept it and I still
have friends you know all over most of
my friends are still from Montreal right
I was raised with them I went to
Centennial Regional High School and this
is the greatest city and it doesn't even
compute with them because I don't think
they understand what freedom actually
tastes like yeah and and that's what's
made me I mean I was you know working as
an actor professionally at 12 the kids
show Arthur remember scene are was a big
production company there and so I
learned about taxes really really young
and we've had family members die die
flat-out die because of health care
where they would have been saved in the
United States
yeah and it's it's one of those things
when I saw you and I was reading up on
you and learning more and more I'm going
like gosh dude these people weren't
there when I was there Sun News didn't
exist when I was there do you think that
the tides are turning a little bit
there's somewhat of a revolt that that
maybe didn't exist before I left in 2005
yes and I think technology is a big part
of this video podcasts Twitter right all
these different ways to get out and
eventually you're never gonna change the
non curious people if they want to
believe women get paid less for the same
work they're gonna believe that you know
people become more steadfast in their
beliefs when confronted with data that
contradicts their beliefs true however
for the curious out there there's more
and more information and and all you
have to do is look under the rock and
see that this racist hellhole America is
not a racist hellhole right and you have
to move there for a little bit and give
it a go
it's just regular how whole sometimes
were you conservative or were you more
right leaning was that why you moved to
the states or did you become more
conservative being in the states we
couldn't make any money in Montreal you
know if much vice went under a few times
and first we were dying because we're
being strangled by this fake welfare
program which was how we were born and
then we were dying because we were
living in socialist Montreal and we got
some investment and said the only way
we're gonna turn this into a profit is
to be in America where people like
profits you know Canada I love Canadians
and I love the pub culture up there and
I love the fries and those women in
Montreal are too pretty I'll never real
law in Montreal it's not fair all that
walks down the street every woman in
Montreal should wear a burka okay go
ahead fun oh I'll never forget when we
vacationed in Montreal and I'm hitting
puberty right at the time and everywhere
I look gorgeous girls everywhere it was
insane whenever we had a band stay at
our house and they said what do you guys
want to do the the city's you're yours
and they say we just want to sit on a
stoop with a king can and look at chicks
amazing looking women there
the 14 sent all the saucy broads over
because he didn't want any cool chicks
and then they started breeding with the
natives and row yeah but anyway it's got
a lot of good stuff going for it but you
just can't make money it's an anti
profit country and and that's what we're
starting to see here a lot of this this
socialist ethos is drifting down here
and Stephen and I have lived it and
we're maybe it's good that we have
immigrants like us because we go trust
me we've tried to placate these nuts
they only want more right what you know
what's funny and I've talked about this
too so so you've been here right when
Barack Obama ran for president and a lot
of conservatives are saying look at his
policies he wants European socialism
right leftist said socialist is now code
for the n-word and as I said to them I
said well you can't say that to me
because I come from a place where
socialism isn't a bad word it's just
part of the everyday political
vernacular yes just oh so oh yeah
socialist oh you're a socialist you're
part of the liberal part of it what are
you NDP yeah socialism is fine there so
it's nothing right yes exactly and as a
matter of fact if you actually look into
the reasons Quebec wants to separate
some of it could sort of be applied to
Tenth Amendment principles you know I
mean they feel as though they're this
big tax base and they're paying for
people in the other part of the country
and if you actually look at there's a
shred of conservatism in there where
they feel as though they're not being
represented fairly and then they miss it
if the language flaws and the
authoritarian yes missed it by that much
cheese yeah it is a good point and I go
back and forth on that sometimes I'm Pro
separatist because I like the idea of
statism right and and this I don't want
a million flowers to bloom as mal would
say just tons of little countries but
that's not their agenda is just more
more welfare I mean they're on the tea
and they think because they have cubic
or and and what's the other one that
builds the bomb barge a they think cuz
they have two corporations they're rich
and we're holding them back look it up
you're on welfare right I know well
that's the thing and then they want to
separate for their independence and then
provide more welfare Gavin McGinnis we
will bring you back after the break so
glad to speak with someone from my
hometown mo yeah who is also a reason
human being louder with Crowder stay
tuned we are back Gavin McGinnis free
speech podcast you can find it online if
you have the googles which President
Obama apparently does not Gavin thanks
for being back and ok you're settled in
he was making coffee while we were
talking with him and was complaining
about the Nespresso machines now I want
more coffee this is a weird this is a
weird way to start off with this
perfectly Gavin to the belly-flop versus
swine swan-dive
swine dive I guess you can use that too
you wanted to get into that well now
what is your I guess perspective on that
okay here's a belly flop is a shut up
you'd be happier at home let's cut the
crap most women would be happier at home
probably 95 percent they're just
pretending they like work and they have
stupid jobs and they don't even hold a
candle to being a mom so shut up that's
a belly flop a swan dive is look of
course there are women who were meant to
be in the workforce but studies have
shown are showing the vast majority are
less happy since feminism is a
University of Pennsylvania study that
looks 800 women across the board of race
color creed it wage everything and they
were all less happy and then the book
why men earn more than more by Warren
Farrell said broke down life in about 25
choices and he discovered that women
tend to choose more family based events
and forego work and then end up making
less money get promoted less that's a
swan dive right
what's more effective I don't know that
well I will tell you this the swan dive
no one would ever seen it anyway
exactly and maybe the belly flop people
go what an ass and then a few curious
people go I'm gonna find data that
refute oh right oh it's true
well I agree and I think I and this is
actually a book that I'm writing and
it's funny I pitched it to a bunch of
conservative publishers back when I was
still attempting to swan dive properly
and they said well we're doing we're
doing Obama doomsday books right now and
this is funny and it's just it's too
offbeat and we just know and so it's
like okay so I just put in my back
pocket but it's funny because we've
talked about this there are two
different kinds of leftists okay there's
the what I call the American Idiot
twist on green day the people who just
accept what's been prescribed to them by
the culture at large
yeah for them it's just fashion right
it's just this is what you believe and
that's that's the easy going with the
grain and then then they're there the
modern leftist the Sean Penn's the James
Cameron's the people who are proactively
manipulating and want like Barack Obama
does he not know those stats I think he
does and I think he wants to make sure
to keep that divide in existence between
men and women Americans divide and
conquer and so he manipulates that and
so I think there are two different
approaches I think what the American
Idiot I'm sorry there is you can reach
them you can change their minds with the
modern leftist you cannot because they
have a vested interest like you said
they're confronted with data they're
willing to to dig their heels in so with
them I think you need to make an example
of them so that you can reach the
American idiots following them does that
make sense yeah and that's my goal I
mean the goal here is helping women I'm
trying to share joy believe it or not
right and by saying to women that are
over 30 check your ovaries look it up
I'm trying to make them happy every
single twenty-something I know not only
says she doesn't want kids but talks
about it like it's disgusting yeah and I
think feminism has brainwashed them into
thinking that having a baby is for
sellout loser hillbilly
nothing's and abortions and condoms are
empowering I mean even lesbians in
lesbian porn not for men I'm talking
lesbian by lesbians for lesbians they
used contraception on the sex toys it's
like empowering to them yeah so that's
the bizarre thing I've ever heard on
this program I know I've forgot to ask
you like a song yesterday about it
yeah it's anyway we won't get into too
much detail but it's confusing and then
every 40-something I know is saying what
have I done they're asking me to hook
them up with my single friends and I
don't know how to say my single friends
are shallow they don't want you and
they're spending tons of money the ones
that do a man on in vitro like tens of
thousands of dollars yeah and and in
vitro is bizarre you know it gives you
quintuplets know
knowing that four will die it's it's
some sick god play I know an old
old-fashioned it's kind of like that
down periscope movie that everyone else
is going nuclear yeah I'm gonna stick
with the diesel sub exact like if it's
not broke don't fix it right and if you
are one of these freaks who's meant to
be totally male and not have kids by all
means go bananas but we're at the point
now where the majority think they're
this freak like Kennedy you know Kennedy
on fox business yeah she would love to
be at home with her kids but she was
cursed with a gift to do incredible TV I
mean she reads the teleprompter like
Mozart right and she's great on the fly
she's great she had this big fight with
John Bolton a few months ago that was it
was like what she the the greatest
boxing match I've ever seen and she's
like I'd be done it's like LeBron James
he'd be dumb not to play basketball but
you're not all LeBron James right now
feminism feminism is at a point where
they all think they're LeBron yeah and
you know what's funny is so we did a
video this week you probably won't see
any I'll send it to you afterward where
we asked people about the definitions
like thug riots and every what fun
what's funny is everyone across all
different colors and genders recognize
the same people thug so you had black
people who recognize both black people
and white people when we showed them a
slide shows thugs and white people who
recognized the same both black people
and white people as thugs but what we
did find was when we asked people about
microaggression the term have you heard
it have you heard of this term
not a single person including black
people had heard of the term the only
group that had were gender studies
feminists those are the yeah exactly and
they went 60 grand into debt learning
that made-up language it's like Klingon
and I always say like lawyers learn a
crazy mixed-up weird language that no
one speaks but they use that in court
when these genderqueer graduates start
talking everyone goes what the hell is
intersectionality right it's not on it's
not on
Webster's calm it's not in the
dictionary well the reason the language
is is right they say thug is the new
n-word and when we ask people everyone
said no I think that's a racist
statement to make because you're
applying something to black people that
can apply across the board I mean
everyone agree yeah yeah the bikers in
Waco are just as much of a thug
Mike Brown you know what it is science
stem is hard science is hard but it's
fun to sound smart so what they've done
is they made up a fake science it's like
astrology and they've made up these fake
words and they've made up all this fake
data so they can put on a lab coat and
play science man and you're like Bill
Nye within the scientific community he's
not really respected as a peer but
anyway yeah they make up all this fake
science and then they come storming at
you and they say white male patriarchy
is raping women white men are the reason
there's sexism when you go really in
2005 ten white men raped black women
37,000 black men raped white woman now I
don't want to make it about race but if
you want to go there we can go there and
the numbers ain't pretty lady yeah I
don't have the numbers in front me what
I was going to get thirty seven thousand
four hundred and sixty versus ten good
lord well like you said we're not you
don't want to be the one bringing it to
the racial discussion but that's the
thing is they only see race and the
thing about the microaggression and the
thing about dog is the new n-word
socialist is a new n-word the one common
theme the common thread through all of
that is leftists are creating a language
that allows them to attribute a motive
to someone without ever having to prove
it right say thug I can mean a biker bar
I mean you know we're from Montreal
biker gangs were legendary between Hells
Angel Hawk machine thoughts machine
exactly and you what's funny about them
they actually weren't motorcyclists they
were a gang and they said well the big
thing is motorcycle gangs in Montreal
guys so Kuwait can we all get Harley's
and I think a good portion had like
import Japanese bikes like they were
yeah the Hells Angels were totally
confused by their stupid bikes moped in
Vespas yeah then they would slit your
throat yeah oh you know it's interesting
Crowder we come from a place where we've
seen what happens when they try to
control the language they take Polaroids
of stores you get fines your company
gets shut down Zach because you're too
English so when we see liberals trying
to control the language and divert the
conversation and say thug and
starting this new committee to monitor
comedy clubs and you can't say rape
jokes and you can't and this is a code
word for this and we're gonna put all
the whites in one room we've been there
and we go no no don't try to control the
language it always gets worse it's gonna
snowball right well and then also what's
funny is I say this and people don't
believe me when we we had a black cast
on Phil I don't know his last time felt
from the advice show and he was talking
about how you don't understand you know
as a white American systemic
discrimination and I go well first off
there is no systemic discrimination in
United States there's a black president
of the United States okay there are
plenty of individual racist absolutely
but actually as an english-speaking
Canadian born to a french-canadian mom
you know which complicates the laws even
more I've faced more systemic
discrimination in North America than
probably any other group Kent I had to
go to French schools they thought I was
learning disabled and I wasn't learning
disabled I just couldn't do math and
geography and history in French I was a
step behind everyone else and I wasn't
allowed to go to English schools yeah
you want to talk about systemic you
force someone to be French you're in
their brain I mean you're controlling
their thoughts that Quebec isn't happy
until you're counting money going in D
spank pound
I don't send home exactly they want you
to literally dream in French I know I
know aunt and when people I go know this
is what systemic discrimination is in
Canada and what's funny is it also
results in secondary increased racism
because we were talking about this
French Canadians right they create in
fund if you don't know this the term
pure Flynn right means pure wold of pure
blood of French European blood if they
want and Quebec and well they created
these language laws right to sort of
purify the province and so what happened
a lot of Haitians started immigrating
because of the huge Haitian French
community and French Canadians and it
totally diluted the whole pure French
thing yes
what are you capable of thinking in both
French and English like totally just
thinking it either is I'm not I mean I
can think in it I probably can think
more clearly in French that I could
speak because of the verb tenses I mean
you know Gavin it's like a it's like a
it's it's a perishable skill you lose it
if you don't use it enough and it's a
stupid language
but what when I think of thinking in a
different language than you're like
Native common language it reminds me
there I think it was a Clint Eastwood
movie about he had to fly a helicopter
and he had to think it in Russian
because it was controlled it was it
might have been somebody else other than
but at any rate there was this movie
where the guy couldn't fly a helicopter
unless he thought about it in Russian
because it was a helmet that he wore to
fly the thing yeah that's a trip and our
immigrants today they come to this
country and they hate it and they don't
want to learn it but the way white
people are when they immigrate somewhere
else I mean they really get into the
country and I lived in Taiwan for a
while and there was this Canadian guy
there who married a Chinese woman we
were both teaching English and he had
Chinese kids and he would just sit
reading the Chinese paper you know every
day and talking to his kids sounding and
trestle hey whoa chill out sir welching
sure and he was just a Mandarin dude and
I couldn't wrap my mind around that but
it's it's what big part of what Quebec
is going for I don't know how this all
ties together but I don't know either
but it's interesting
one thing that's amazing about Quebec is
after the referendum the biggie that was
in the 90s 96 or something that Jacques
now he's oh and all that yes okay
there's emigrate yes they lost a
separatist election and he said you know
whose focus is the immigrants and the
English yeah but anyway walking down the
street that week if you were speaking
English to your friend
you felt audacious yeah and it was it
was a brave thing to do it was crass to
just walk down the street and say hi Joe
how are you today and that is the
culture room with political correctness
if you are at work and you're talking to
someone and there's a slightly sexual
tinge to your joke and women are in the
room you feel like you're speaking
English after the referendum in Quebec
and I remember that feeling and I don't
want to feel ashamed I don't like
feeling guarded so political correctness
is a great example no sorry it's a great
analogy here with Quebec separatism and
Quebec French yeah I think you're right
and you know what Gavin I think what you
just said took you more than 45 seconds
on a panel would allow you and I think
that's why you are a belly-flop or for
better or worse and that's a good thing
I think the digital age the internet
revolution allows someone like you to
have a voice and have the time needed to
to let that voice get out there you know
well that's the second part of the
debate sorry I keep interrupting I had
too much coffee this morning but the
second debate is is it up to you whether
your belly flop or swan dive
you know Roger Ailes says if you you are
yourself you're unstoppable and I know
that's weird to say to you yeah I think
you just have to go
I would love to swan dive I would love
to sit there and delicately lay out the
figures but I'm Bluto from Animal House
I can't help but go when the Germans
bombed Pearl Harbor did we quit no come
on
Germans who cares he's rolling yeah it's
great film it's funny my video producer
hasn't seen that one oh that's cause
he's 12 when people haven't seen Animal
House he hadn't seemed slapshot either
or 1941 you know knows I can live with
it really I don't know I'm not a fan of
people not being a fan okay okay I can
sleep at night if they haven't seen 1940
when people haven't seen Animal House I
get chills I know they're multiplyin
yeah I well we're actually going to do
the most offensive video in internet
history and just have all of those
quotes from those old films we're that
you just can't say today dude that's so
funny you say that because I'm going to
break the world's record for a video
podcast by talking about Animal House
for 48 hours nice that's very nice
I didn't mean to spill the beans but you
made it irresistible well listen if
you're doing guests I'll be there I'm an
animal house fan and I know you're gonna
have a tough time getting conservative
pundits to come on and opine about
little boo tarski well especially
because it's gonna be five to forty six
in the morning on a Tuesday night I know
okay listen Gavin we have to let you go
but
let's get you back soon and coz because
I also want to talk about your
transition it's no secret your pretty
pretty profane out there guy and you
talked about having children and how
that changed you into believing in God
and sort of you're on this faith journey
which I also find interesting so will
you come back soon in the program I
would love to come back and talk about
the Lord talk about the Lord which also
funny fact about Quebec the single most
unchurched population in the
industrialized world Gavin McGinnis free
speech podcast working people best find
that one I'm sorry you can't just go out
on that there's less churches in Quebec
there in anywhere I don't know
unchurched but probably the most
beautiful churches in North America the
old Catholic churches but the most one
search meaning people don't attend and
people don't care about ills
that's our losing my religion was huge
in Quebec it was it was yeah Quebec but
we have to let you go where could people
that's fine your podcast uh check me out
on Twitter Gavin underscore McInnis free
speech podcast is on iTunes it's on
dailymotion I'm around
alright Gavin thank you very much we
will be back louder with Crowder and
have Gavin on some time soon stay tuned
subscribe by clicking my face and if you
hated it well join the club and you're
gonna hate this next video right next to
me but doesn't a part of you know what
it is